[Music]
on this monday night russian missiles
strike a mall in central ukraine
the crowded building bombed
and president zielenski's pleas to g-7
leaders as his nation's culture is
caught in the crosshairs it's about
russian's idea that ukrainian identity
does not exist the final days of
abortion services in tennessee it's
health care and it should be accessible
what the state's lawmakers are now being
urged to do preparing for partiers and
protesters the fears of what could
happen on canada day in the nation's
capital
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin in central ukraine where scores
of civilians are feared dead after two
russian missiles struck a busy shopping
mall
images from the scene show giant plumes
of black smoke the shopping center
engulfed in flames ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky says the number of
victims is impossible to imagine citing
reports more than one thousand civilians
were inside at the time the mall is in
an industrial city in central ukraine
far away from the epicenter of russia's
war which has recently been focused on
the eastern donbass region
russia is stepping up its strikes across
ukraine yesterday rockets were fired
into residential neighborhoods in kiev
today vladimir zelinski underscored the
urgency of improving ukraine's military
might to world leaders including prime
minister justin trudeau at the g7 summit
in germany our political correspondent
david aiken is there david
we'll need to the ukrainian president
was at an undisclosed location in
ukraine and beamed in virtually to have
a meeting with g7 leaders at the resort
here at the summit site it was a
two-hour discussion a closed-door
discussion leaders talking about
everything from war strategy to
ukrainian reconstruction it's clear
ukraine still needs help on a global
scale but vladimir zolensky says his
country needs help getting ukraine's
agricultural exports around russian
blockades canada is pitching in with 52
million dollars in equipment and
technology because russia is weaponizing
the food
and particularly destroying the food
storages and the logistics
um
the importance of this
financial support and commitment to
support ukraine in movable grain
storages is very essential
zielinski also wants even more sanctions
on russia canada moved on that front too
imposing sanctions on a new group of
individuals and banning exports of
certain kinds of canadian technology to
russia and it's no secret that zalenski
continues to look for more munitions and
weapons from the west to that end the
u.s said monday it will send
anti-aircraft systems to ukraine the
support of the weapons the military aid
is now crucial to stop booting and to
stop russian war which weaponize food
weaponized energy supply
like killing ukrainians g7 leaders
though are united that there can be no
escalation of the conflict beyond
ukraine's borders we are also cautious
that we will help the ukraine as much as
is possible but that we also avoid that
there will be a big conflict between
russia and nato the g7 leaders also want
help help from countries that have yet
to sanction russia and so the g7 invited
the leaders of india south africa and
argentina three big countries that have
yet to even condemn russia's invasion to
ask them to do more to join the west and
put more pressure on vladimir putin
when trudeau and modi met for a brief
one-on-one russia's invasion was on the
agenda but there may be more that the g7
can do there were discussions to get
started in a process to cap the price of
russian oil and that of course would
have the effect of eliminating some of
the revenue that the putin regime is
relying on to prosecute their war in
ukraine
david aiken in germany thanks david
those sweeping sanctions have pushed
russia to default on its foreign debt
for the first time in more than a
century russia missed its sunday night
deadline to meet a 30-day grace period
on interest payments of more than 100
million dollars moscow denies the
country is in default calling the claims
unjustified the kremlin has the money to
pay thanks to oil and gas revenues but
sanctions have frozen its foreign
currency reserves abroad
when russia invaded ukraine in february
it was clear it wanted more than control
of its neighbor it also targeted
cultural assets the russian military
struck several museums and art galleries
precious artwork is missing while other
artifacts have been destroyed ukrainians
say their culture is under attack and
they're fighting to save it sean o'shea
reports from ukraine tonight
for months ukraine's stages and theaters
have been closed because of war but
slowly they're coming back
[Applause]
despite war we believe that cultural
institutions should operate if it's
possible it's both important for the
public for them to attend
defending their land ukrainians are also
in a fight to preserve their cultural
identity war is about identity
it's about
russians idea that ukrainian identity
does not exist and ukrainians do not
exist as
as a separate society it's a view openly
held by russia's president vladimir
putin
russian
propaganda
machine works that ukraine do not have
their culture they do not have their
history they don't have their national
and cultural identity so it should be
destroyed it should be shelled it should
be looted that's what happened in parts
of ukraine since the invasion museums
and galleries and other national
treasures have been targets it's
obviously a war crime and crime against
humanity ukrainians are resisting to
defend their culture just as their
military is resisting to defend the
country
this new contemporary art exhibit is
provoking ukrainians to express
themselves including how they feel about
the war people should
fail and should speak about their
feelings and
this exhibition is about that
outside the recently reopened opera
house in keeve on a saturday afternoon
patrons have come to see the ballet
this woman gets emotional she says she's
here because her grandson's fighting in
the war she needed an escape others are
making a point of showing defiance also
russians wants to destroy our culture
and our language and
we want to do everything to support it
to defend it they want to steal
everything from mezzo soprano katarina
simbaluk a plea to defend culture and to
keep supporting her country ukraine now
as a shield of all europe because nobody
knows if we will not stop putin here in
ukraine we don't know
how far he can go he will not stop and
ukrainians say they won't stop doing
what they can to preserve their culture
charles shea global news kharkiv
nato says it plans to massively increase
its rapid response force from 40
thousand troops to more than 300
thousand canada has up to 3400 army air
force and naval personnel on standby for
deployment today nato also released new
defense spending figures marking the
eighth consecutive year of increased
spending across european allies and
canada last week canada committed nearly
five billion dollars to modernize norad
defenses but as our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stephenson reports there's
confusion over where the money is coming
from
the liberal government's promise to
spend 4.9 billion dollars modernizing
continental defense was carefully staged
on an airfield complete with a cf-18
fighter jet backdrop
while the look was sharp the details
were not the minister contradicted
herself on the source of funding first
saying it was from the 2022 budget
through the 8 billion dollars in the
most recent federal budget minutes later
that changed on top of the 8 billion
dollars
in the federal budget
that would be a lot more money but
within an hour her office said she had
misspoken national defense sources tell
us it wasn't just a muddled public
announcement even the military didn't
know where the money was coming from and
there are concerns it may not be new
money at all but rather funding cut from
existing programs training and
operations in a stunning admission
canada's top soldier told the west block
even he doesn't know the answer i
haven't completely figured out myself
this the source of funds for this so i
can't i can't say definitive
definitively where it's coming from you
know i will say though the announcement
was welcome
for four days global news has been
asking the minister's office to clarify
whether the money is new or will be cut
from within the department they have not
responded with an answer i think
increasingly there'd be
some concern about
us essentially playing a version of a
shell game the big thing here is the
inability of this government to be
honest with canadians about what they're
paying for security experts say
inflation is putting increasing pressure
on the canadian armed forces who cannot
stop training or operating despite the
increasing security and financial
pressures all while our nato allies
expect more former defense minister
peter mckay says he thinks the
government probably plans to put in new
money from the budget but canada's foot
dragging on defense spending and
politically rushed announcements aren't
a good look canada will will suffer a
significant
blow to its credibility a significant
undermining
of canada's role in in nato
sources with international allies say
they are curious to find out more about
the funding too and hope they'll do so
at the nato summit from the prime
minister
nithu mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks
turning now to the u.s where more states
continue to ban abortions following the
supreme court's ruling to overturn roe
versus wade on friday in places where
trigger laws haven't yet come into
effect like tennessee as our jackson
prosco reports from nashville there's an
urgency to provide or coordinate
services before legal access to abortion
is blocked
the doors open for the final week of
abortion services at the nashville
planned parenthood clinic where they
will stop accepting patients as of
friday
the clinic's website warns that due to
recent changes in tennessee law they can
no longer provide medication or surgical
abortion services they can only help
women travel out of state for care we
don't want anybody to wait and thinking
that this is going to get better because
it's only going to get worse and it's
going to get worse really fast in
tennessee the clock is now ticking on a
trigger ban of almost all abortions at
the end of july
any day before that the state's courts
could overturn a stay of an existing
heartbeat law banning abortions after
six weeks nobody's looking at this as a
full picture abortion is not black or
white the looming loss of abortion
rights prompted taylor eschee to go
public with her own story i don't think
anybody should feel alone abortion is
completely normal it's healthcare and it
should be accessible last summer taylor
was stunned to learn she was pregnant
despite using birth control
at 28 and running her own business she
and her fiance made the difficult
decision to end the pregnancy i don't
have anybody to cover for me maternity
white maternity leave wise i'd have to
pay myself that i have to pay for child
care because i do not intend to stop
working
and unfortunately if i were to have that
child like i would have built every lost
everything that i've built
in post row america women face a
patchwork of bans and choices
some states have vowed to go so far as
to prosecute women who travel for
abortions
others have expanded and protected
abortion access in their laws
advocates for reproductive choice warn
many women will be unable to travel and
will simply fall through the cracks
in states like tennessee they're calling
on lawmakers to deal with the
consequences of banning abortion in this
new chapter where people are going to be
forced to carry their pregnancies to
term or have to leave the state to
access care that we'll have policies
here that can actually take care of
families because we're going to have to
here in nashville the local district
attorney now says he will not prosecute
doctors who provide abortions or the
women who seek them and that puts him at
direct odds with the state's attorney
general who's actually trying to
accelerate the timeline for implementing
the state's trigger ban on abortion
nether
jackson prosco in nashville tennessee
thanks jackson
bracing for mayhem on canada's birthday
coming up the concerns about protesters
crashing the canada day party in ottawa
plus a rare frozen find in yukon more
than 300 centuries in the making
and nasa's astronomical feat in the land
down under
3
two
one
a sky-high achievement from down under
nasa just launched a space rocket from a
commercial spaceport in australia a
first for the country and for nasa
outside of the u.s the rocket is
carrying scientific equipment that will
help study star systems only observable
from the southern hemisphere two more
launches are planned from the australian
space center for later in july ahead of
the canada day-long weekend ottawa is
preparing for its first celebration of
the national holiday since 2019 and
while concerts fireworks and other
activities are on the agenda the city is
also closing roads and calling in
reinforcements to keep anti-government
protesters from disrupting the capital
like they did in february abigail beeman
has more
preparations underway for the first
almost normal canada day celebrations in
three years it's pretty amazing i mean
it's the first time we've all been
together since covert this family from
montreal vancouver and amsterdam picked
ottawa for a canada day reunion it's
daniel's first time in the
do you want to capital it daniel but
with hundreds of thousands expected to
descend on the downtown core there's
also some anxiety about so-called
freedom protesters among them this
business owner in the tourist popular
byward market is still deciding whether
to open it's just a question of
how many protesters or that kind of
thing they're expecting down here so we
don't like trouble they're not going to
be warnings and second chances if the
law is broken regardless who breaks it
there'll be consequences ottawa police
are promising swift action for any
illegal activity
after being widely condemned for not
stepping in sooner during the original
convoy
you're not going to be allowed to set up
speakers to have a dance party or any
sort of tents to be able to camp or
have any sort of structures and we've
been very clear on that we are not
setting up an encampment in the city of
ottawa we are going to be at a campsite
40 minutes east of the city while a key
group organizing activities this weekend
in various places around parliament hill
is trying to calm resident anxieties
we're not monsters like the media is
portraying us to be
we're not violent there's a whole
continuum of violence and i think what
we saw in in february in particular was
the violence of words the violence of
taunts the violence of symbols and i
don't know that we're hearing enough
from conference organizers to really
make it clear that they understand that
side alex neve is a commissioner for the
newly launched grassroots ottawa
people's commission gathering
experiences of those impacted by
february's convoy he says anxiety
remains high in the community as canada
day looms and people aren't sure exactly
what to expect
abigail beeman global news ottawa
ahead the terrifying stadium collapse at
a colombian bull fighting event
a dramatic scene at a colombian bull
fighting festival has left at least four
people dead after a three-story section
of the audience stands gave way it's
unclear what caused the collapse that
also trapped and injured hundreds of
others but the improvised stadium held
together by bamboo was called unstable
by officials colombia's president-elect
is already urging for a ban to bull
fights noting similar incidents have
occurred at such events
minors digging for gold in yukon have
uncovered something even more remarkable
the mummified baby woolly mammoth was
found in the klondike gold fields nearly
a week ago geologists believed it died
and was frozen in the permafrost during
the ice age more than 30 000 years ago
it's the first near complete and best
preserved woolly mammoth discovered in
north america
the biggest tournament in tennis stands
against russia next the athletes being
served the consequences
more than a dozen of the world's top
tennis players definitely won't hold the
sport's biggest trophy this year though
the uk's wimbledon tournament is well
underway but a ban on russian and
belarusian athletes has barred them from
competing including the number one men's
player of course the move is a stand
against russia's devastating invasion of
ukraine but it's not without controversy
here's eric sorenson
wimbledon with its green grass red
strawberries and all-white dress code
for players can be an escape from the
world's turmoil not this year the
biggest stars are playing but not the
russians to blunt the propaganda
benefits that vladimir putin and russia
derive from their international sports
figures wimbledon has banned players
from russia and belarus government
industry sport and creative institutions
are all playing their part in efforts to
limit russia's global influence but the
men's and women's tennis tours opposed
the move believing individual players
should not be targeted so they stripped
wimbledon of the points normally awarded
from the tournament my honest opinion i
think it's i don't think it
was a good idea to ban the russian
players to play i think medvedev
is the best we have in our sport right
now daniel medvedev is the top-ranked
men's player in the world he's not at
wimbledon but like many russian athletes
is careful about criticizing russia or
the measures to punish russia i always
say that i have to follow the rules
and where i can play i'm going to play
i'm going to try to play my best
russians can play at the upcoming u.s
and canadian opens ukrainian player
elena's vitalino wants greater support
from sports governing bodies our sports
is thrown back
by 10 years
minimum
because
all the all the
infrastructure
being damaged or completely destroyed
one academic says international sports
cannot divorce politics from sports and
have failed when trying to be neutral in
trying to maintain neutrality
it really played into putin's hands the
institutions the organizations that put
on these events
have to be cognizant of international
affairs the nhl is one international
league that did not look to ban russians
such as alex ovechkin who opposes the
war but has openly supported vladimir
putin for the lone russian on the
champion colorado avalanche there is one
setback valerie nachoskin will not be
allowed to take the stanley cup and show
it off back in russia as his countrymen
have done in the past eric sorensen
global news toronto
a newfoundland and labrador woman who
helped people find strength and song has
passed away
[Music]
this choir is special i suppose
if you love to sing or want to sing with
people
you're in
we introduced you to helen murphy back
in 2017 when she was a global national
everyday hero she was the volunteer
conductor of the stella circles
inclusion choir harnessing the power of
music to help people on the edge of
society find their voice some choir
members credit her for saving their
lives helen murphy was 76 years old
that is global national for this monday
night i'm nitu garcia thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]